an epic showdown between a dc vigilante
and a longtime family friend a
reflection on existence the most iconic
high school mega brawl you've ever seen
you may know these shows but you'll be
surprised to see what episodes they
saved for last
mash was met with consistent critical
acclaim during its broadcast run earning
over 100 emmy nominations and winning
14. however it was starting to show its
age by the end at 11 seasons mash ran
over four times longer than the korean
war it depicted and outlasted the
vietnam war it was protesting yet the
series proved it was still an emotional
powerhouse with its heartbreaking 1983
series finale goodbye farewell and amen
in the final days of the korean war u.s
army surgeon hawkeye pierce is under
deep psychological evaluation after
enduring a complete mental breakdown as
the horrifying circumstances behind what
finally broke hawkeye come to light each
of the medical camps main characters
endure their own tragic reminders of the
costs of war for a sitcom mash closes
its celebrated tenure on a particularly
dark note
then again given its constant message
that war is hell its characters were
never going to receive a perfectly happy
ending
for its first couple of seasons star
trek the next generation struggled to
find its own voice as it forged a new
future for the science fiction franchise
by its third season the series had not
only visibly emerged from the shadow of
its predecessor it had also begun taking
big creative risks the original star
trek never attempted this was evident in
the season 3 finale the best of both
worlds part 1 which closed out the
season with a cliffhanger that had
audiences eagerly waiting for the
subsequent season premiere as william
riker mulls over passing on
opportunities to command his own ship in
favor of remaining on the enterprise the
ship faces a renewed push by the
villainous borg this leads to captain
john luke picard being turned into a
borg drone and used against his old crew
as the ultimate weapon
picard confronting the enterprise as a
borg in the season's final moments
catapulted the next generation ahead of
viewer expectations as the show boldly
went where no star trek series had gone
before
[Music]
created by aaron sorkin the west wing is
a master class in how to weave larger
narrative payoffs while telling
stand-alone stories the series season 2
finale two cathedrals not only follows
up on plot threads first introduced in
the first season but also ends on a
cliffhanger that spurred considerable
interest in where the show would go next
the whole episode is elevated by a
powerhouse performance from star martin
sheen as the overwhelmed president
josiah bartlett as president bartlett
and the white house staff mourn the
death of bartlett's personal secretary
mrs landingham a scandal is brewing for
the administration season one revealed
bartlett and his closest associates
covered up his multiple sclerosis
diagnosis a secret that could carry
legal repercussions and derail
bartlett's chances for re-election two
cathedrals marked all the crises and
issues facing bartlett coming to a head
with bartlett finally venting his grief
and anger the episode truly elevated the
west wing to the level of prestige
television
the acclaimed showtime series dexter
chronicled the murderous adventures of
dexter morgan the sinisterly charismatic
protagonist who lived a double life as a
serial killer in miami while dexter
certainly had close calls across the
first several seasons he managed to keep
himself and his family free of deadly
consequences stemming from his murderous
secret this all comes to an end in the
season 4 finale the getaway as dexter's
vendetta against the devious trinity
killer takes a gruesome personal toll
much of dexter season 4 involves a tense
cat and mouse game between dexter and
arthur miller a seemingly mild-mannered
family man discovered to be the
notorious trinity killer by the end of
the season arthur discovers dexter's
true identity this changes the morgan
family forever and looms over the show
in its revival series dexter new blood
dexter morgan has always been a
character who managed to stay one step
ahead of his prey you're like a child
child with a big knife
unfortunately for the title character
the getaway made the cunning killer
appear shockingly weak
over the course of breaking bad high
school chemistry teacher walter white
transformed into a manipulative drug
kingpin riveting television audiences
while many moments demonstrated just how
morally bankrupt white had become the
season 4 finale showcased the
protagonist at his most cunning in one
fell swoop white took out one of the
most devious villains the show ever
introduced while keeping his business
partner jesse pinkman under his thumb
ever since white partnered with local
crime lord gus fring he realized he and
jesse were at his mercy with his
relationship with fring becoming
increasingly strained during season 4
white is pushed to the breaking point
before he pulls a last minute victory
breaking bad works best when walter
white is backed into a corner and forced
to think his way out of a predicament
faceoff delivers on this score
for years how i met your mother played
the long game teasing out the identity
of protagonist ted mosby's future wife
eight seasons in the sitcom's
overarching narrative began to feel like
a cruel and relentless emotional roller
coaster for its romantic protagonist
fortunately the season 8 finale
something new not only revealed the
mother but also set the stakes for the
series 9th and final season as divisive
as the how i met your mother series
finale has remained among fans the
season 8 finale promises a story to
remember as it places each of its main
characters at a crossroads something new
delivers on the long-awaited promise of
the series giving audiences a glimpse of
ted's true love how i met your mother
may have lost some of its momentum
across its run but the season 8 finale
got its groove back and officially
kicked the show's end game into motion
with its change in networks and often
uncertain future the animated series
futurama has crafted plenty of season
finales that could work as the series
last episode however the one that worked
the best was its season 7 finale
meanwhile which closed out the show's
run on comedy central
for a show with a surprising amount of
heart futurama saved its most touching
note for what could have been its final
episode as fry prepares to use one of
professor farnsworth's devices to stage
the perfect scenario to propose to lila
the time manipulating invention
malfunctions the combination of the
show's typical sci-fi danger combined
with the joy of seeing fry and leela's
romance reach its sentimental apex
meanwhile is a pitch perfect ending an
absolute powerhouse of an episode the
intended series finale sets a high bar
for futurama before it makes its return
for new episodes on hulu what do you say
want to go around again
i do
arrow was always a sort of strange beast
a fact that tends to get lost amid all
its spin-offs and shared universes grim
and gritty the series reimagined dc
superhero green arrow as a lethal
vigilante who felt like an archery
themed mix between batman and the
punisher by the end of its first season
arrow finally found its rhythm in a
truly spectacular final episode that
defined the show and its approach to
protagonist oliver queen the season 1
finale sacrifice featured ollie's epic
showdown with the dark archer revealed
earlier in the season to be long-time
family friend malcolm merlin as
flashbacks reveal how ali became adept
at archery the present-day storyline
demonstrates these skills aren't quite
enough to save the day with merlin
emerging triumphant no season finale of
arrow delivered the same amount of
tragedy and consequence as the superhero
show finally found its voice
the same day the cw aired the season
finale of arrow they aired the finale of
another hit show what's more the
episodes had the same title supernatural
creator eric kripke initially pitched
the horror drama series to conclude with
its fifth season but the season eight
finale sacrifice proved there were
plenty of surprises still to be had as
sam winchester undergoes a set of trials
to protect earth from demons his brother
dean faces his own divine test from
heavenly angels although dean and sam
came back from the dead so often in the
show that it became something of a joke
the stakes in the season 8 finale were
still high with both brothers poised to
make the ultimate sacrifice castiel and
crowley both lost their powers adding to
the intensity supernatural went on to
run for a staggering seven more seasons
but sacrifice reminded audiences that
the show still had some tricks left up
its sleeve standing out as a harrowing
convergence of all its epic plot threads
while the office remains one of nbc
universal's most popular sitcoms the
show definitely took a turn when it lost
series star steve carell ed helm's
character andy bernard dutifully took
charge of the workplace but the show's
final two seasons felt directionless for
its fan favorite cast while the ninth
and final season is widely regarded as
an improvement over its predecessor it
isn't until the series finale that its
story clicks into place the office's
narrative setup was about a documentary
being produced chronicling the staff of
a paper company working out of scranton
pennsylvania the final episode aptly
titled finale jumps ahead a year in the
future after the documentary finally
premieres with the characters reuniting
to reflect on their journey together
finale really hammers home how much the
audience has come to love these
characters in the show's bittersweet
farewell
hbo's game of thrones may have left
audiences and actors alike divided over
its series finale but the epic fantasy
drama set high expectations with its
season 7 closer the dragon and the wolf
with the threat of the white walkers
bearing down on the continent of
westeros jon snow and daenerys targaryen
appeal to their enemy houses to stand
together against the undead army as game
of thrones finally brings its pieces
together to set up the eighth and final
season the series leans into what it
does best there is only one war that
matters
the great war
and it is here
from long time rivals finally coming
face to face to peter baelish being
outsmarted at his own manipulative game
the dragon and the wolf is the show
firing on all cylinders the episode also
delivers one of the series best
cliffhanger endings between seasons as
the wall that historically kept westeros
safe finally comes crashing down game of
thrones was always full of nail-biting
anxiety since no character was safe but
the season 7 finale pulled out all the
stops
following in the footsteps of the karate
kid the legacy sequel series cobra kai
has introduced its own generation of
martial arts rivalries stemming from
daniel larusso and johnny lawrence's
feud while the students of daniel's
miyagido karate school and johnny's
kobrakai dojo squared off before nothing
has impacted the show's trajectory quite
like the season 2 finale no mercy after
months of mounting tension the two dojos
battle each other in the halls of their
high school the fight quickly goes off
the rails with tragic consequences cobra
kai had plenty of thrilling fight
sequences before but nothing quite like
the climactic high school brawl at the
end of season 2. in a truly impressive
technical feat an extended unbroken take
follows the two dojo's trading blows
cobra kai has always successfully played
off viewer's nostalgia while
simultaneously modernizing the karate
kid legacy and the season 2 finale shows
just how far its young cast has come i
mean somebody royally forked up
somebody forked up
why can't i say fork
compared to some other shows on this
list the good place intentionally ended
its run at the top of its game rather
than attempting to inflate its
overarching story for a few more seasons
as such series creator michael sher
mapped out a trajectory for the show
that concluded its story with its fourth
season the series finale whenever you're
ready delivers on the show's concurrent
themes of mortality as it delves into
the happy endings of its main characters
the good place was always packed with
jokes but brought in a surprising amount
of genuine heart behind its characters
especially in its later seasons the
series finale gave each of its main
characters the opportunity to reflect on
their own eternal existence with some
opting to continue and others ready for
one last farewell for what began as a
relatively nonsensical comedy about the
possibilities of the afterlife the good
place saved its ultimate philosophical
and emotional payoff for its curtain
call check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]